me so leveling up is not a jam
spreading operation it's not robbing
peter to pay paul it's not zero sum
it's win-win for the whole united
kingdom and and so this is the plan and
i
i will believe uh that we've made
progress on leveling up when we've begun
to raise
living standards spread opportunity
improved
our public services and restored
people's sense of pride
in their community across the whole of
the uk you've got to begin by getting
the basics right and we've got to begin
by fighting crime
because we will never level up across
our country while some kids
kids face the the mis the the misery of
of dealing with the uh the county lines
drugs gangs
and some kids do not and that's why
we're putting rings of steel
around towns that are plagued with these
gangs and steadily
driving them out and so far we've
squeezed more than a thousand
county lines drugs gangs out of business
and that's why uh we're we want tough
sentences
we're imposing tough sentences and we're
recruiting 20 000
more police and we'll be we'll be
ruthless
in fighting crime because it is the
poorest and
most vulnerable who suffer the most and
obviously to give kids alternatives to
these gangs we'll invest in
all sorts of things but particularly
grassroots sports
and i can today announce another 50
million pounds for instance for football
pitches
so that we give new opportunities to the
the football stars
of the future and that ultimately you
are never more than 15 minutes away
from a high quality football pitch and
we won't succeed in leveling up when so
many people
are off work because they're sick or
stressed
uh or because they suffer from obesity
or problems with
their mental health and that's why we
are tackling those problems tackling the
problem of
junk food we're rewarding exercise and
we're investing colossally more than
ever before
in our national health service building
40 new hospitals
recruiting 50 000 more nurses we're
going to deal with the backlog of those
waiting for elective surgeries and
the single biggest thing we can do of
course
in addition to investing in in public
service to change
people's lives and to give them the
confidence
and the serotonin that everybody needs
to deal with the
the day is to give people the chance of
a
good job on decent pay
and that means the private sector has to
invest
to create those jobs and we must
create the conditions for business
confidence and when
people look at the west midlands here
where we we are today
the birthplace of the industrial
revolution place that changed the world
they remember and you remember this
unbelievably
uh the number of private sector jobs
actually fell
uh three percent under the last labour
government
in the west midlands and they know one
of the the reasons
for that lack of productivity one of the
things that was holding the west
midlands back has been the lack of
mass transit the lack of public
transport the basic difficulty
of getting from your home to your place
of work and that's why
i support your vision andy for putting
in those new
metro lines and that's why today i'm
fulfilling
my promise to give eight city regions
like the west midlands the funding to
start making their bus
and train networks as good as london
by launching our city region's
sustainable transport fund 4.2 billion
pounds
that local leadership can spend on
projects like contactless
ticketing new tram lines bike lanes
and i speak of somebody who's put in
more bike lanes probably than anybody
else
in this country uh they are they're
deeply resisted by some people but
overall
they are massively popular and i
thoroughly recommend them
and this is part of the biggest
infrastructure investment in the history
of our countries 640 billion pounds
on roads on rail on housing
clean power generation we will use the
findings
of sir peter hendy's union connectivity
review to see how we can strengthen the
sinews
of the whole united kingdom getting hs2
trains
to scotland giving new impetus to
projects that benefit
the whole country the a1 the link
scotland and england the a75
that links uh northern ireland and
scotland and england uh the links into
wales along the m4 corridor
uh the the a55 dozens of other crucial
projects long overdue like the a303
to the greater southwest and we've made
huge progress by the way in rolling out
gigabit broadband throughout the uk when
i became prime minister almost exactly
two years ago
seven percent of the country as i never
tired of saying at the time
seven percent of the country had gigabit
connection by the end of this year we
will be hitting
60 percent and that has the potential to
revolutionize
our patterns of work and provide a
tailwind
for leveling up and no matter how
frustrating we may find life
on zoom we can see how this technology
and its successors will allow the places
that have
been left behind or felt left behind to
become places that
retain their talent and professionals
will be able to
stay and bring up their families and
enjoy
a higher quality of life without the
need
to move to a supposedly fashionable
conurbation
and we're also helping young people to
fulfill their dream of
owning the home they whether in a place
where they want to live with
our 95 mortgage guarantee as well as
reserving a portion of homes in some new
developments
for first-time buyers at a discount of
at least
30 percent and this government is
backing
the improvement of the lives of people
growing up
in these areas with the leveling up fund
4.8 billion pounds
spent to be spent across the whole of
britain england
scotland and wales and with town deals
with another
15 of them announced today helping local
people to renew
the places they live from the civic
square in tilbury
to the hippodrome theater in modern
removing
chewing gum graffiti breathing new life
into town centers through our high
street strategy which is also
published today and though the overall
uh
that each change may be individually
small the overall effect
can be transformative in making that
environment
attractive as a place to live and to
bring up a family
and to invest and of course what is the
key question that people
ask themselves young families ask
themselves about a neighborhood
it's not just whether it's safe and all
has a good transport
it's whether the schools are good and we
need to give
all our children the guarantee of a
great education with safe and
well-disciplined classes
fantastic teachers so we are literally
leveling up
funding for primary and secondary
education with a higher level
of funding per pupil so that every
teacher starts
on a salary of thirty thousand pounds
and
we must face the reality that in loss of
learning
and loss of life chances some children
have been hit harder by this pandemic
than others and so we've put in place
the biggest tutoring program anywhere in
the world to help them catch up
a catch-up program by the way that is
already worth 3 billion
on top of the 14 billion pounds that we
invested as soon as this government
came in but it is in post 16
education post-16 where the
differences across our society are
starkist
it cannot be right that bath has
78 percent of its population with a
level 3 or equivalent
qualification bradford has only 42
and that's why this government is so
obsessed
uh the chancellor everybody uh rob
generic
we are all obsessed with skilling up our
population
we love our universities we believe
they're one of the great glories
of this country but we need to escalate
the value of practical and vocational
education with its power to transform
people's lives and that's why we're
rolling out t
levels and apprenticeships because we
know
that higher level apprentices can earn
more than the average graduate
five years after graduation that's why
we're creating the lifetime skills
guarantee so that adults
can go on to get those level three
qualifications
and so as we improve skills and cut
crime
and upgrade transport and ensure that
gigabit
broadband is extending its invisible
electronic
tendrils into every home in the country
and opening up limitless vistas of
information
and opportunity by that process
we want to make the whole country more
attractive
for investment